[Music]
rosie is based on rosie the riveter the
very famous icon during World War two
error to get women involved in a lot of
the mechanical work we use foam for the
head as well as some of the parts so
even though it was relatively basic it
was still you know achievement because
we worked overnight we started off with
a remote-controlled car and we used the
chassis of the car to experiment with
the robot on top of that whispered Rosie
into two electrical circuits the bottom
portion was meant for the movement of
the robot controlled by a mobile app and
the top portion was meant to capture
their facial expressions and as her
response offered to shake their hand the
app that was meant to control the car
base wasn't actually working and we
spend a lot of time on the app but
looking at all the settings but it turns
out that we just hadn't connected the
Wi-Fi antenna to the harder it was just
you know really cool to you know not
have to worry so much about having to
you know create a you know whole new
library and whole new set of tools and
instead use you know what was already
available to get started a lot quicker
when I heard that they were gonna you
know have a third-party developer
finished sort of the design work that I
was working on and then the see in
person and see that it was literally the
same height as me maybe a little bit
taller with the Will's I was beyond
ecstatic about it it was really cool
[Music]
when we first got the project for Rosie
there was a prototype and our job was to
make it bigger make it so she could take
pictures with you drive around an event
and make her have a large presence in a
conference setting there are some really
big motors down in that base they're
actually from electric wheelchair we
have two car batteries wired together in
series to make sure she has enough
voltage enough amperage to be able to
get around the board inside Rosie is
capable of all kinds of different ML
functions it's kind of thing with Google
API so by adding some external sensor
store we're able to increase their
functionality and interact with people
at a much higher level you can actually
do on device processing and use all the
Google services that are actually
available and pick and choose API is
that you really wanted to to use the
biggest thing that I learned to us to
use the platform itself now it has
inspired me to start a new project and
it's become so easy to work on them with
Android things it's really cool because
it allows you to you know just jump in
the injury things team has a lot of
support on their website and has a lot
of tooling that's readily available so
you don't have to just start from
scratch try out a few code labs
once you try a code lab or two you will
get the hang of it and then you can
build your dream project give it a try
go download Android studio get a
Raspberry Pi get one of our development
kits and just get started
[Music]
you